what's up chess fans in case you missed
it yesterday may 26 was a really weird
day in the world of chess our beloved
world champion Magnus Carlsen created a
chess calm account named menu garden
with the goal of becoming number one
blitz in the rankings and then deleting
his account and retiring from playing on
the site while he was ultimately
unsuccessful in this goal he did provide
us with very entertaining games over the
course of six to eight hours and he even
live-streamed all of them along with his
patented dry humor the game that we
chose for you today was one where he had
the black pieces against very talented
grandmaster Louis soupy who's 23 years
old and a rising superstar he's
currently I believe number 4 in the
rankings in Brazil but I believe in the
next few years he will break 2600 and
potentially approach 2700 let's see what
happened when the two of them clashed
Louis supey started the game with E 4
and Magnus busted out the Scandinavian
defense which he has played in blitz
quite a bit after 85 Queen d5 the less
popular night of three not taking
advantage of the Queen's placement
immediately was played I actually play
Knight f3 myself and my semi efore
repertoire and after Bishop g4 Bishop b2
knight c6 black is taking an approach of
just very quick piece development he's
not putting any pawns in the center of
the board he wants the castle quickly
and fight against white potentially
expanding with d4 but here we see Lewis
throw-in Knight c3 put the Queen back
and challenge the LightSquared bishop on
g4 Magnus opts to trade right away and
then castle and white castles as well
and Magnus here has a lot of natural
looking moves east 6e 5 maybe g6 maybe
Knight f6 moves that you know to the
untrained eye look like they all kind of
do the same they're just trying to
develop but what Magnus notices is that
this bishop is extremely powerful and so
he decides to play Knight d4 trading it
off immediately
now here Lewis with the white pieces
also can play a lot of natural looking
moves but he plays one that looks to
directly take advantage and challenge
Black's setup things are castled on the
opposite sides of the board that should
be a little bit of a hint for all of you
that attacking one another is going to
be far easier than normal and so Lewis
plays a4 and the move a4 is you know one
is just to throw the pawn forward but
another idea of this move is to
potentially play Knight b5 targeting
both pawns and offering a trade of
knights which would open the position
for the rook the other idea is that if
this Knight were to take the bishop
which it did after the following moves
king b8
Knight b5 we just see this idea Knight
takes f3 Queen takes f3 you have a
situation on the Queen side where it's
just a bunch of pawns a queen and a king
and when you don't have knights or
bishops guarding your king it can be a
little bit easier for the attacking side
to break in either using their pawns or
their pieces since the King really
should not be the line of defense
guarding the entrance into his castle
now I should just say that Knight b5
here taking is way too dangerous because
again your queen should also not be the
defensive resource for your King safety
and here there's a really nice move by
white Roux k3 trying to go rook b3 and
target the b7 pawn and while black can
play still moves like c6 trying to block
the LightSquared bishop it is far too
dangerous with moves like d3 and Bishop
e3 coming every single piece in White's
position is about to be lined up to the
king this is not recommended so instead
Magnus plays Queen f3 and says Louise
please get your night out of here in
scaring me and Louise says I'm not going
to be getting my knight out of there
I'm gonna play C for now c4 is is is
what I like to call a gangster move I
mean it's it's it's flamboyant it's
beautiful chess he's saying listen take
my knight when you take my knight what's
gonna happen is I'm gonna open up a
direct line of attack toward your King
and this this looks extremely dangerous
for black especially because Queen a3
and Queen here is just devastating and
you know if you play a move like east 6
to stop the Queen from coming to a3
I'm gonna play Queen b3 Queen a4 I'm
still gonna find a way to get to that
side of the board and defeat you and I
think both players here
have overlooked I mean dare I say
overlooked the defensive resource Queen
d3 and actually taking the knight and
then playing queen d3 puts a bit of a
stoppage in whites plans the only way
now to get the Queen to the other side
of the board would be to play something
like Queen d1 and then here maybe there
is an opportunity for you to take this
pawn and stop Queen a for if you play e6
Queen a4 is still coming and maybe you
can try to evacuate the king but
obviously this looks quite dangerous
although black with some good play can
hold the fort
Magnus chose to not take this risk but
sometimes in chess you have to and
Magnus play d5 e5 is a very natural move
activating the bishop and here Lewis
played another very very good move he
brings more pieces to the party but he
doesn't do it in a slow way he plays d4
at first glance that move looks like it
just loses a pawn and actually that's
exactly what Magnus played but the point
of this move is to disallow either of
these pieces from getting into the game
he's forcing his opponent to react to
the pawn danger if you don't react you
play something like 97 I'm just gonna
take and I'm just gonna win a pawn even
though your knight gets here and defends
your King I will be up upon so a very
difficult decision for Magnus Carlsen he
plays this move d4 a magnus decides to
take but when this pawn comes here now
we see the whole points Bishop a4 now
another piece joins the attack and the
c7 pawn is under pressure Magnus can
play something like Bishop d6 but after
it takes takes c5 taking advantage of
this pin blacks position is falling
apart very very quickly and so now
Magnus thinks that he can take the
knight and at first glance it really
does look that way he recaptures and
plays Bishop d6 a good strategy when
you're under attack is to trade off some
of the attacking pieces and that's
exactly what Magnus is doing here but
here Louise comes up with an absolutely
brilliant and astonishing idea for two
of them actually the first of which is
just to play the very calm rook a to
so now if Magnus continues with the plan
of getting this Bishop off the board we
don't even take we go rook here we
threaten mate and the position is it's
it's lost I mean it's completely lost
from black he has to defend in some
really crazy way by like giving away the
bishop but then somehow giving a check
and trying to evacuate but he's gonna
lose a lot of material in the process so
after rook a to Magnus decides to play
Queen f5
and Queen f5 looks like it you know
you're threatening Queen f4 which will
kept the Queen's off the board and you
have this escape for the King so it
looks like things are under control
now row k1 threatening checkmate alright
threatens mate Magnus shows the
secondary idea of evacuating with the
Queen place king CA
and now if you pause the video here and
think how is white going to win this
position you're gonna struggle and I
highly recommend that you do it try to
find how white is gonna win this game
it's very difficult to be forcing here
I mean rook 8 8 the Kings just getting
away there are some crazy variations you
can play Queen takes pawn but here Louis
shocked everybody including Magnus
Carlsen by playing the astonishing move
Queen c6 I'll move that at a low depth
the engine doesn't even see it needs to
be at like depth 2019 to see something
like this
Queen c6 I mean the point of this move
is very straight forward actually it's
just a stop King d7 and if takes takes
it's just a stop King d7 and somehow
despite having five extremely powerful
pieces on the board there is no way to
prevent Rik a a no way you can give a
check you can block for a moment but
this is coming and there is nothing that
can be done when Queen c6 happened on
the board
Magnus is demeanor went from super
relaxed to Wow
that and I'm pretty sure he was even
quoted as saying things like that's it
you know that that's dirty and but but
he was I mean he was super super super
complimentary of his opponent and it was
you know it was just kind of nice to see
like sometimes you know that you just
missed a move and there's no you know
there's no anger or ill-will associated
just you just kind of raise your hand
and go wow that is an astonishing move
Queen c6 the purpose of which can be
really boiled down to the fact that it's
a checkmate net the checkmate net is
when you surround the enemy king prior
to delivering a check by taking away its
escape squares this one is just more
flashy than others and it turns out that
taking the pawn on d4 was the fatal
error
Magnus did have to play 97 giving away
this pawn and bringing the knight to the
defense of not only a7 which is this
side of the board in general but a
brilliant game and hats off to Magnus
for being good sport and we expect to
see much more of Louis soupy in the
future
hopefully you enjoyed this recap of very
very interesting brilliant game
brilliant attacking game little
miniature there from the white side
somewhere on the screen there should be
other videos like the video if you
enjoyed drop a comment below let me know
your thoughts and I will see you on the
next game of the day recap gear for
chess calm